well the golden knights are skating
toward the opening of the 2021 season
chris matthews skated in off the streets
with more from today's kfi chris
hey listen i didn't use my best double
axel right here as i rolled in here
hey hey yeah but the knights were
getting fired up they're getting further
for the season players and coaches
how about peter deboer they've talked
about this team a shortened season
no preseason games it's going to be a
challenge throw in the fact that kobet
is still lurking out there and
it'll be another interesting and very
unusual year how about the teams and
players affected by this
that's why they added scout players in
today's scrimmage there was one ghost
sighting jonathan marchandso
scored the only goal as the team gets
ready for the season opener one thing at
camp
you can now see clearly peter deboer's
stamp on this team
i think we have a great game plan you
know we got
you know pete's been with us for i don't
know how many games but we're
getting more used to the system and you
know we believe in the system and the
more we play
in his system we'll you know the better
we'll be so you know like i said we got
a lot of talent
um but the way we play we all believe in
it and bought into it and the more we
play it uh i think the better we're
gonna get
harder to play against for sure i don't
remember deboer was hired last winter
about this time actually prior to the
pandemic so he hasn't really been with
his team for a full year
so we'll see his stamp on this team as
the season opens this month knight's
first game
will be at home they'll host the anaheim
ducks on january 14
over there at t-mobile arena christian